in 2021 the Apple app store bought in a
total of $85 billion worth of Revenue
out of this 20 to 25 billion dollars
went straight to Apple this itself is
insane but if we look at it in terms of
profit Things become even crazier
historically the app store has boasted
an operating margin of 78% meaning that
$17.5 billion of this is pure profit for
perspective apple as a whole Nets $114
billion per year meaning that the App
Store alone accounts for over 15% of
Apple's entire bottom line Apple
currently boasts a valuation of just
under 3 trillion with $114 billion worth
of profit so with $17.5 billion worth of
profit You could argue that the App
Store itself is worth roughly $460
billion that would make the IOS app
store the 15th largest company in the
world even if you want to be super
conservative and cut that valuation in
half we're still talking about a market
cap of2 $30 billion which would still
make the App Store roughly the same size
as Coca-Cola or Toyota and when you zoom
out this is really not all that
surprising given that the App Store was
responsible for $1.1 trillion worth of
transactions in 2022 for perspective
even Amazon only boasts half that
Revenue but forget companies with $1.1
trillion worth of essentially GDP value
the App Store would rank as the 17th
largest country by GDP but if it was by
no means an easy Journey getting here in
fact Apple initially didn't even have
plans of launching such an app store and
Steve Jobs insistence of doing
everything the Apple Way has caused
quite a bit of trouble for Apple in
regards to the App Store so here's the
full story of the Apple App Store and
how powerful the App Store really
[Music]
is with how successful the app store has
become it's natural to think think that
this was always part of apple or more
specifically Steve Jobs Grand Vision for
the iPhone but that's not actually the
case in fact the original iPhone didn't
even have an app store and while Apple
was working on an app store in the
background it wasn't meant to be
something big it was just supposed to be
a place where users could download
auxiliary apps from Apple themselves in
fact Apple had no intention of letting
third party developers onto the App
Store at all Steve Jobs figured that
developers could just create web apps
that could be run on Safari this would
be easier for developers to adapt their
existing platforms and easier for apple
as they wouldn't have to police the App
Store but developers weren't exactly a
massive fan of this idea they would
protest on forms and purposefully avoid
creating mobile versions of their web
apps but what really pushed things over
the edge was the jailbreaking Community
just a few days after the iPhone
launched developers would put together a
jailbreak for it and just a few weeks
after this the jailbreaking Community
would come out with the world's first
iPhone game called lights off lights off
was a very simple straightforward game
that never really caught on but it's
what it represented that really mattered
this game was an assertion from the
developer community that if Apple wasn't
going to directly allow for Native
development they were just going to do
it on their own and that's exactly what
happened in October of 2007 the
community would release an easily
accessible jailbreak called apps snap
which came with its own app store called
installer.app
this would quickly evolve into Cydia
which I'm sure you're all familiar with
and it's what finally got Steve Jobs off
his high horse the same month that
installer.app was released jobs would
release an open letter to the developer
Community he didn't quite apologize for
his previous stance but he did announce
that a native app store was coming very
soon imagine if jobs hadn't relented
Cydia would have become magnitudes
larger than it did as a lot more
developers would have jumped on board
Apple may have even been forced to
support Cydia at one point if it became
widespread enough but but fortunately
for Apple Jobs made the right choice and
launched their own app store on July
10th 2008 with just over 500 apps on
paper the launch was a massive success
within just the first weekend the App
Store would reach 10 million downloads
just 2 months later they would reach 100
million downloads and within just 9
months they would reach 1 billion
downloads but putting these insane
numbers aside Apple was actually having
quite a tough time internally because
Steve had insisted on doing everything
the
[Music]
appway despite technically giving
developers what they wanted with the App
Store Apple was still receiving a bunch
of backlash from developers likely the
biggest reason for this was that Apple
was forcing developers to use apple
tools to make apps xcode and UI kit
since then we have seen Alternatives and
more neutral languages pop up like
flutter but the bread and butter of
Iowa's development is still xcode which
a lot of developers are still quite
salty about in fact that's why xcode has
a relatively low rating of 3.1 Stars
it's not that xcode is bad per se but
simply that a lot of developers are
still pissed off that they're forced to
use it but this issue with the
developers was the least of Apple's
concerns when it came to the App Store
likely their biggest issue was actually
supporting the insane scale of iOS
development with something like Windows
this was never a problem because
Microsoft does doesn't really control
what can be installed on Windows
machines so all they had to do was
create an open platform and support a
broad range of implementations
everything else was up to developers
whether it be testing or distribution or
scale the same however could not be set
about the App Store you see while Apple
does allow developers to make apps for
their various devices iOS is still not
an open platform it's more of a quasi
open platform as every single line of
code that makes its way onto the App
Store store has to be manually reviewed
by Apple on one side this largely limits
what developers can and cannot do and
that's why Joe breaking and Cydia were
so big despite the App Store on the
other side this ensures that everything
on the App Store is of a certain level
of quality and doesn't contain malware
or viruses or anything harmful this is
why all iOS apps have a certain aura
about them when it comes to UI and
completeness but this also means that
Apple has to manually review every
single version of every single app yeah
I think you can see why that would be
rather hard to manage and apple doesn't
take these reviews lightly either of
course you'll hear about something that
slipped through the cracks here and
there for example they once accidentally
approved an app that would straight up
let users CH break their iPhone but for
the most part Apple's review system is
very robust in fact 40% of App Store
submissions are rejected largely due to
nitpicky things for example a keyboard
might have been partially covering up a
text field which made the UI not as
pristine sometimes Apple will even
reject an app on the basis that they
don't think it's valuable for users but
not only does Apple Pride themselves in
picking out the smallest of mistakes but
they aim to do it within 24 to 48 hours
again I don't think you'd be surprised
to hear that Apple has 500 people
working full-time to review iOS apps but
not only is the App Store labor
intensive it's also Capital intensive
going back to Windows for example if you
want to download Photoshop shop you
would head to adobe's website and it
would be up to Adobe to ensure that
their website and servers can scale to
demand with the App Store however it's
all up to Apple AKA they currently have
to support 142 billion downloads every
single year with the average IOS app
being 34 megabytes we're talking about
4.8 exabytes or 4.8 million terabytes
worth of downloads every single year
clearly following the apple way with the
app store has cost Apple quite a bit but
but fortunately there was gold at the
end of the rainbow which brings us into
the economics of the App
[Music]
Store apple has a few ways of monetizing
the App Store starting with directly
charging developers every year each
developer has to pay Apple $100
technically there is a free tier that
you could use to mess around with coding
iOS apps but if you actually want your
apps to end up on the App Store you got
to get the pay tier as of 2022 Apple had
a total of 34 million registered
developers how many of these developers
are on the pay tiers unclear but it's
very possible that this fee alone
generates over a billion dollars in
annual revenue for Apple given how much
Apple makes off the app store though
this pales in comparison which brings us
into Apple's main mode of monetization
the Apple tax for apps that generate
less than $1 million per year developers
have to pay 15% ta to Apple and for apps
that generate more than $1 million per
year developers have to pay 30% recently
these fees have gotten a lot of
criticism as being the 30% Apple tax
that's applied to all revenue that goes
through the App Store but that's not
quite how it works I mean think about it
$1.1 trillion worth of Revenue goes
through the App Store if Apple charge
30% on all of that that itself would be
$330 billion worth of Revenue or a whole
another 3 doll company while the App
Store is extremely lucrative it's
nowhere near that lucrative in reality
Apple actually only makes 20 to $25
billion per year from the App Store so
in terms of percentages they're only
earning 2 to 2 and a half% of the
revenue that passes through the App
Store and this is how Apple largely
defends their 30% fee but that's not to
say that the fee is small like apple
claims either the reality is that
Apple's fee is quite large but not to
the people that you might think take
take Amazon for example they don't
release official Revenue stats for their
desktop versus their mobile app but
according to sellers it's usually about
a 640 split with the majority of Revenue
coming from mobile AKA Amazon pulls a
nearly $300 billion every year thanks to
their IOS and Android apps but it's not
like they're paying a hundred billion
dollar to Apple and Google who by the
way has nearly an identical pricing
model with the Play Store how do they
avoid this massive fee you ask well it's
not due to some sort of secret
background deal though they do have that
as well the real secret is simply that
Amazon has the authority to directly
charge customers almost everyone has
their credit cards directly linked with
Amazon so Amazon has virtually no need
for Apple's payment infrastructure which
is where the Apple tax actually applies
it's basically the same case with every
other big company or financial platform
these guys can charge you directly so
they don't have to deal with the Apple
tax the only notable exception to this
role is is streaming services people
often subscribe to streaming services
out of impulse and forget about it and
these streaming Giants don't want to
lose out on customers by slowing down
their process and asking for credit card
details so they'll often just use
Apple's double click to pay stuff with
that being said though you should be
careful when subscribing to these
Services through Apple because it's
often more expensive YouTube premium for
example normally cost $14 per month but
if you buy it through the app using
Apple's payment infrastructure it's $19
per app to account for the 30% tax so
all of the big companies that account
for the vast majority of the $1 trillion
going through the App Store don't even
have to pay Apple a dime if they don't
want to the people who actually end up
paying Apple a boatload is smaller
developers who are solely dependent on
Apple's payment infrastructure which is
usually game developers people like
robtop from Geometry Dash supercell from
Clash of Clans and Clash Royale or
Nintendo these guys have been trying to
fight the Apple tax for years and it
seems that Microsoft has also also
joined this fight which is not
surprising given their recent gaming
Acquisitions but the Apple tax still
stands hopefully with time these guys
can bring down the apple tax which would
be huge for smaller developers but
honestly it doesn't really matter for
Apple because in the end it doesn't
really change how powerful the Apple App
Store really is with historically High
interest rates the appeal of bills and
bonds is higher than ever yet
traditional brokerages haven't really
adapted with the times these still
expect people to use clunky Bond tables
scroll through long overwhelming lists
and even use Virtual keyboards till
recently and that's why we created our
own modern Bond platform Silo at Silo we
prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust so that you
too can easily lock in high yields also
choosing a strong user experience does
not mean sacrificing unsafety every
salow account is insur insured by
$500,000 in sipc insurance and $2.5
million in FDIC Insurance also all funds
deposited on the platform will be
maintained by our trusted custodian
interactive brokers who has experienced
managing $373 billion worth of assets
over the past 45 years so if you're
looking for a modern way to invest in
bonds please consider checking out Silo
in the description below if you think
the Apple App Store is too powerful you
should check out Android because they're
on a whole another level check out this
video to learn more but until then I'm
Harry I'll see you guys on the next
one